the whole basis of the movie is you go
out and you do pranks
and you incorporate them into the movie
yeah and i love that kind of thing i
mean sasha baron cohn
does that kind of thing but what you do
is you're like [ __ ] any social relevance
you just go out for the laugh right i
mean like sasha's like like hey i'm
trying to teach you
the evils of the world right your
attitude is like [ __ ] that
i wanna die yeah i'm gonna be stupid and
i'm gonna risk my life
[Laughter]
when you're planning a stunt you say to
yourself okay i got this great idea
i'm gonna go to a zoo sneak into the
gorilla cage
i'm gonna get a selfie with a gorilla no
[Music]
oh my god okay he's a human being
that was one of the first things we came
up with i think we wrote that during do
you remember harambe
remember the kid fell in the gorilla
enclosure oh yeah yeah he was whipping
him around and that was big news when we
started writing the movie and
so we thought like the funniest prank is
if i was
in the harambe situation i fell in the
gorilla cage
but instead of getting whipped around by
the gorilla the gorilla just starts
[ __ ] in the ass
he starts [ __ ] me in the mouth at one
point other gorillas come out and start
[ __ ] me in the ear
like a whole jungle gangbang was going
to happen first of all
what kind of zoo allows you to even set
up how does that
look like like if you go to a zoo and
say look we're gonna have gorillas come
out we're originally gonna do it at the
atlanta zoo
uh and they were like oh yeah we love
pranks let's do it here and then we told
them what the prank was
and they were like absolutely not yeah
so we had to go out and
we had to go like four hours into rural
georgia
when you were putting together the movie
and you're doing all these pranks
sasha baron cohen like he said hey bring
your movie over
yeah and i would love to see it and i
could give you some advice
because i've done a lot of these things
yeah like that that's
incredible to me that's really generous
oh he's a sweetheart for no money for no
just just out of the kindness of his
heart he was like come over to the house
well drink some wine
bring your director bring your producer
and we
sat in his living room no like in his
little office upstairs that we showed in
the movie and he just like
gave us a ton of advice and feedback and
he was like this is working great this
needs some help
and he's a total mensch you know he's a
hero
he's like the obi-wan kenobi of pranks
so
i sat very quietly i listened to his
every word i really like hung on
i'm usually like but i just sat and
listened